[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone in case you're wondering
what's with the music well a hundred
years ago on 24th of February 1918
Estonia declared its independence and
today on 24th of February 2018 Estonia
is celebrating its 100th birthday so I
thought what would be a nice way to
commemorate this milestone well I
thought I should show a very nice game
played between Michael Tao and Paul
Karras so the Estonian powerhouse Paul
carrots versus the magician of Riga and
this game features it all it has
everything sorcery piracy very nice
counter-attacking tall moves I mean it
features everything and it's also a game
from the 1959 candidates tournament like
we've seen in my previous video where
you saw how many cut out beat Paul
Karras in the end you also heard that
Karras won three games and fell only won
one game in this tournament so once
again we should marvel at this photo it
was taken by Goomer viola it was the
photo is from the match Estonia vs lot
we also played in the spring of 1959 and
don't worry there will be a link in the
description below for you to enjoy this
photo you can use it as your desktop
wallpaper or maybe for your home page on
your smartphone so yeah and it was the
match was played in the capital of
Estonia in Tallinn so a nice photo as I
don't have any other photos from the
1959 candidates so that being said let's
see this game in this game
Tull has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 notice that tall doesn't go for
a 4 against Carris we have Knight to f6
c4 and East 6 Knight to c3 and the
Bishop to b4 Karras goes for the
nimzo-indian defense we have f3 known as
the covariation
d5 a 3 now and Bishop back to e7 we have
E for bite al D captures on e4 FCAT rose
on e4 and now the immediate 'if I've
sort of looks like black is offering
upon here
but not really you can't really capture
it because after Queen captures now if
you capture with the night black will
simply capture on e4 and if you capture
with the Queen King then comes Knight g4
threatening I have to check and also
grabbing back the pawn so you'd have to
defend this and then Knight captures and
always well for black black is even
better here so after a five we have d5
now I'm grabbing space in the center and
we have Bishop to c5 immediately bye-bye
Karis Bishop to g5 we have a five now
not allowing tile to push b4 to kick
away that Bishop Knight to f3 and now
Queen to e7
we have Bishop to d3 and now comes
Knight B to d7 and Queen to e2 h6 now
forcing child decide what to do with the
Bishop Bishop back to d2 and now c6 so
Harris wants to do something about tall
strong center central pawn chain we have
Knight to a4 attacking the bishop and
here you know a lot of players would
consider a lot of moves I mean your
night that night is awkwardly placed on
a4 so definitely you want to leave it
there but moves like Bishop to a7 come
to mind although then your rook will not
be defending the a five points so you
don't really consider that but players
would consider what a move is like
Bishop d6 but then of course you have to
worry about ideas like rope c1 and c5
and but in the end probably the best
idea would be to push b5 the bishop is
protected by the Queen but again tall
doesn't want to doesn't want a carriage
doesn't want to allow tile to play
Knight captures on c5 as he really likes
that awkwardly placed nighttime a4 so
here top plays Bishop to b4 with a
different idea we had Knight captures on
d4 pawn captures on d4 and Bishop to f4
now by tall and here if you if you
decide to castle then Thal has this very
annoying
'if I've move so first caris plays
Knight to e5 himself stopping e5 and
here it's a it's a perfectly nice
position for white talking simply castle
play Bishop captures on e5 a lot of
moves are interesting here but you know
tal is haunted by the possibilities of
the position and he decides to do a
different move he plays Knight to b6 and
although this seems a bit dangerous
maybe even maybe even you know what what
scare is gonna do here he can't really
move the rook on a seven or a six then
your Bishop is undefended on c8 and if
you play something like rook to b8 then
you're getting in the line of fire of
the bishop on f4 but here tall missed
Karis counter-attack Karras goes for
immediate Bishop to g4 removing the
bishop and now this comes with an attack
on the Queen now plays Queen c2 and now
comes Knight captures on b3 with check
first Queen captures on d3 and now comes
Luke to a6 and now tau is in trouble as
you can see the rook is attacking the
knight nb6
but that's only half of the problem the
night here is is kinda needed as the
knight is guarding the d5 pawn so black
will be able to capture it if the knight
moves also you don't want to play
something like Knight to a4 so when
presented with a choice of giving up the
central pawn or giving up a piece tile
decides to give up a piece and in this
position Tulp cancelled so Karis isn't
really impressed with Tulsa sorcery and
he simply captures the knight rook
captures and b6 and here if you were
playing this position you'd think okay I
just gave up a piece so my king is safe
he castled and i definitely want to play
something like e v maybe push d6 then c5
will also be an option maybe put a B for
the break open on the Queen side get
this rook activated but not tall tall
goes for another immediate tall move he
plays Bishop to d6 so sacrificing a
second piece just to make the attack
happen a little bit sooner now if you
don't capture the bishop if you move the
Queen then c5 is coming your king will
be stuck on the 8th as the bishop is not
is preventing the King from castling so
Karis again isn't very impressed
he simply captures the bishop we have
Queen captures on these
and here tall pushes a five now of
course if you capture the pond which
Queen captures then you get rook 81 you
lose the Queen
but even after losing the Queen it would
still be you know playable for black
because black would have a rook a knight
and the bishop for the queen but the the
sea and the advance the D pawn will be
definitely making the position better
for white so after this if I move Karis
goes for Queen to e7 and now you can't
capture the night if you capture the
night you get Queen to e3 check Karis
would exchange Queens and with being up
a piece it would be easily winning
position for him so after Queen to e7
tile activates his last rook he plays
rook a to e1 and now he's ready ready to
capture some pieces here Knight to d7
was played and tal pushes East six so
again threatening to capture the night
and also threatening the f7 pawn
you can't play something like Knight to
f6 because it captures on f7 check wins
the game immediately so after each six
carries plays F captures on e6 and here
you do have a lot of options here
definitely for white and one idea is
something like Queen to g6 check after
the King moves you can simply simply
gobble up the bishop threatening the six
pawn but now Karis would simply push a
five and Talas attacks the Talz attack
is prevented
so after this F captures on e6 tile
plays another towel move he plays c5 and
the idea of c5 is is completely beyond
me I mean of course he's attacking the
rook but there are a couple of options
here for black black can play rook
captures and v2 he can play Knight
captures on c5 and he can play Queen
captures on c5 so both of these I mean
all three of these options are good for
black in the game Karis played Knight
captures on c5 wooden attack on Tallis
Queen and here top played Queen to g6
check now of course you only have two
options you can play King the d7 and
King to d8 of course if you go King to
d7 you lose the game due to rook to f7
check sorry rook to f7
and your only other option is king to d8
which was played in the game by Karras
and here again you have a lot of options
here one idea is to try try the rook f7
idea but then Kari says Queen to g5 he
would offer to exchange Queens only good
square available for your queen if you
don't want to trade pieces this Queen to
c2 but now Queen captures on d5 and you
don't really you don't really have any
options here you could try something
like beef or after a captures a captures
and rook captures to go through k12
maybe you know try threatening checkmate
or something but 96 simply locks off be
a file and there is nothing to do here
with white so after this King to d8 move
Tull tries another idea he goes for b4
he wants to open up the Queen side here
we have a capture some before but now
first tile captures the bishop on g4
Queen captures on g4 and here we have C
captures on d5 now as you can see after
all is said and done Karis still is
upper piece and he has this massive pawn
chain in the center and the window
spawns start marching forward it will be
very dangerous
Queen to G 3 by tau tau is now
threatening Queen to b8 check with some
with some nasty ideas one of them being
to win the rook on h8 so Knight to d7
guarding the b8 square and now a capture
some before
caris definitely has the time to capture
before porn but you know you don't want
to be too materialistic against all
allowing radius like rook to a1 maybe so
first he plays rook to f8 actually wants
to exchange now as many pieces as you
can look captures we have Queen captures
and now b5 again an interesting idea
locking that rook on d6 a six and the c6
are unavailable you don't want a really
clear move like rook to d6 and of course
if you capture the pond then rook
captures
maybe on e6 but it's all still you know
very very bleak this is this is a
winning position for black you know only
thing talk it hoped for is for Karis to
mess up so talking tricking
he did in this miss love game but you
know Carris is not the one to be fooled
by by sorcery and piracy so he filed by
Karras we have looked to anyone and now
comes King to c7 not allowing rock
tracer a rock to a check rope the c1
check came to be 8 and now Queen to b3
attacking the d5 1 we have Knight to f6
defending the pawn and now comes Queen
to c2 which the idea of Queen to c7
check so if if Karis for example it's
something like e 4 then he ended is is
getting checkmated due to Queen to c7
check King h8 okay rook e1 check you
have to block this now comes pawn
captures threatening either pawn or
Queen captures on g7 on v7 checkmate I
have to block this again pawn captures
on b7 this is checkmate so this would be
very unfortunate but you know Karis is
not likely to fall for something like
this
so Queen to d8 stopping Queen c7 we have
Queen to f4 now Knight to e4 and now
rook to f1 trying trying to get some
activity for the rook on an open file
Knight to d6 and now comes Queen to a3
now this Knight can't really move if you
move the night you get a rock to see a
rope to f8 but you know it's not a
problem
rook captures on b5 we have rook to a-1
again threatening anything we have Queen
to b6 and after this Queen to b6 move
tile resigned at the game and yes this
time towel definitely did resign the
game as there is really nothing to do
here you can give a couple of checks for
example Queen eight check King c7 and
after rook c1 check rope would block and
there is really nothing more to do here
rook if one simply d3 and the pawn will
win the game either this pawn that phone
or you know however thought would
continue carries would win this game
without a problem so this is one of the
games Karis won against McHale tile in
the 1959 candidates tournament I do hope
you enjoyed it
once again happy 100th birthday to us
estonia so you know quite a milestone
to achieve once again we can marvel at
this photo since you know there's there
are so few photos I mean especially of
this quality of players playing chess in
those days so yeah I do hope you enjoyed
the game as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
probably with another game from the 1959
candidates and just so you know we we
don't forget here are the standings of
the tournament talent first place Karis
in second petrosyan in third Smiths
lovely go rich
bobby fischer friedrich Olufsen and pal
Benko so thank you all and I will see
you soon